-Phoebe, hey.
-Hey.
Hey, look,
I was wondering if maybe you wanted to--
to hang out.
It's the last summer
after high school ends.
The last chance to decide who we wanna be
and who we wanna be with.
I give up. What are you supposed
to wear to a breakup?
How about we agree to stay friends?
Just friends.
Okay. Walk away.
For God sakes.
This is gonna be the summer.
Just clean the slate.
You're really good.
I can't believe you're wasting all this
to study business.
Right?
Over a safe, stable career in the arts.
Hi, boys! Beach bonfire party.
Are you down?
Sure, yeah.
Come on,
I'm not actually gonna go out with him.
No. He's young, successful, and he's hot.
Gross.
So, what's the deal with you and Phoebs?
-We haven't talked about it yet.
-Keeping the mystery alive.
I dig it, man.
Sometimes I fear
whether I'm even capable of love.
Welcome to my office.
You're making it very hard to judge you.
The summer's just going by way too fast.
I wanted to see you
before we both leave for school.
-Hey.
-I gotta go.
But have a nice Fourth, okay?
Phoebe,
there's something I need to tell you.
You just went along and you did nothing.
I didn't know what to do.
I've never been through this before.
One last summer.
The last chance to go all in.
I mean, what's there to lose, right?